el problema nos dice multiplica 6 por 14
simplifica tu respuesta y escríbela como
un número mixto entonces justo aquí
tenemos el 6 y lo bueno es que sabemos
que todo el número entero lo podemos
escribir como una fracción por lo tanto
si tiene sentido tomarme esta
multiplicación de fracciones el 6 lo
podemos ver como 6 sobre 1 y tenemos al
6 el 6 sobre 1 es lo mismo que 6 que es
un número entero ya esto lo voy a
multiplicar lo voy a multiplicar por un
cuarto por un cuarto entonces vamos a
multiplicarlo por un cuarto y lo padre
es que también sabemos multiplicar
fracciones sabemos que es este por este
y este por este así que esto me va a
quedar exactamente lo mismo que 6 déjame
ponerlo con un verde un poco más fuerte
6 que va a multiplicar que va a
multiplicar a 16 que multiplica a 1 y
todo esto
todo esto dividido entre 1
entre 1 que multiplica a su vez a 4 que
multiplica a su vez a 4 ok ahora date
cuenta que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que 6 por 1 eso sí lo sabemos hacer 6
por un 9 6 dividido entre 1 por 4 1 por
4 es 4 ahora ya tenemos está como
respuesta pero si te das cuenta 6 sobre
4 se puede simplificar un poco 6 sobre 4
es exactamente lo mismo que dividir la
parte de arriba entre 2 y la de abajo
podemos dividir ambas partes entre 2 así
que vamos a hacerlo voy a dividir la
parte de arriba entre 2 y la parte de
abajo también la voy a dividir entre 2
porque son números pares y así voy a
poder obtener una respuesta mucho más
sencilla más simplificada 6 entre 2 es 3
a 4 entre 2 es 2
tres medios esta es mi respuesta ya
vista como una fracción simplificada
ahora aquí no acaba la cosa me dice que
escriban esta respuesta como un número
mixto entonces para eso lo que voy a
hacer es tomarme la parte de arriba y la
voy a poner con este color aquí tengo
tres ok voy a tomarme el 3 y lo voy a
dividir entre el denominador recuerda
que tres medios es exactamente lo mismo
que 3 entre 2 3 entre 2 y bueno si te
das cuenta aquí tenemos a amp que cabe
una vez una vez
1 por 2 es 2 entonces esto le voy a
quitar 2 y tengo un residuo de 1 y tengo
y déjame ponerlo con otro color un
residuo de 1 aquí sobra 1 por lo tanto
puedo decir que 3 medios lo puedo ver de
la siguiente manera como un entero como
un entero es justo este 1 de aquí este
un 9 aquí y tengo un residuo de 1 por lo
tanto me queda un entero
un medio el denominador se conserva que
es justo este un medio y ya está aquí
tengo que tres medios es lo mismo que un
entero en medio visto con un número
mixto por lo tanto ya tendría la
respuesta de este problema ahora si
nosotros queremos entender un poco mejor
qué es lo que está pasando en la
multiplicación de estas dos fracciones o
más bien de un número entero por una
fracción lo podemos visualizar la
siguiente manera que te parece si
hacemos por aquí un rectángulo voy a
hacer por aquí un rectángulo esto va a
ser un rectángulo y lo voy a copiar
varias veces déjenme copiarlo ok vamos a
copiar control cm y después lo voy a
pegar ok ya lo tengo por acá y lo voy a
poner justo por aquí y voy a copiarlo
cuatro veces ok voy a pegar otro por acá
ok y voy a pegar otro por acá ok y vamos
a hacerlo otras dos veces más
voy a pegarlo por acá ok es más este
este lo voy a quitar porque lo voy a
poner con otro color si te das cuenta
aquí tengo seis veces un cuarto hasta
aquí hasta aquí llevamos
una vez otro cuarto alba otra vez otro
cuarto ahí va otra vez y aquí llevamos
otro cuarto ahí va otra vez es decir
tengo un cuarto más un cuarto más un
cuarto más un cuarto todos estos cuartos
estos cuatro cuartos forman a su vez un
rectángulo más grande que es un entero
esto de aquí es lo mismo que un entero
por lo tanto déjeme pulsando aquí esto
es un entero ahora aquí llevamos cuatro
cuartos pero realmente lo que estamos
haciendo es multiplicar seis veces un
cuarto por lo tanto me faltan dos así
que déjame a ahora tomar este otro color
y voy a poner aquí los dos que me faltan
aquí tengo uno más
ok más o menos así ok ya este lo voy a
copiar y lo voy a pegar a copiemos
y lo voy a pegar por aquí ok y entonces
aquí tengo dos otros dos que me faltan
por lo tanto aquí llevo cuatro cuartos
más un cuarto más más un cuarto más esto
es lo mismo que seis por un cuarto seis
cuartos ahora estos dos cuartos si te
das cuenta es la mitad de otro entero si
nosotros nos tomamos por aquí a a otro
de verde y le voy a poner más o menos
así ya otro de verde ok los voy a poner
aquí estos todavía no están en nuestra
multiplicación estos están vacíos
realmente lo único que estoy tomando son
dos cuartos más este de aquí y este de
aquí por lo tanto esto es la mitad de un
entero completo puedo decir que un
cuarto no es un cuarto es un medio un
medio y aquí tengo un medio de otro
entero y entonces cuando yo sumo uno más
un medio me da exactamente si yo sumo
estos dos me da un entero un entero que
es justo lo que tengo aquí
medio déjame buscar el color del 2 un
medio y ya está es justo a la respuesta
a la que llegue vista de una manera
visual del lujo nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo